ragazzi miei io sono orgoglioso ma
veramente orgoglioso di poter tornare su
questo capolavoro
non so quanti di voi conosceranno questa
perla videoludica che è veramente
velasco fase si deve solo spostare
schema octo dead deadliest catch ed era
un gioco che di quelli che avevo fatto
tipo agli inizi del mio canale quando
l'avevo aperto
volevo assolutamente di portarlo 1
perché non mi ricordo piena mazza e due
perché era veramente di un'ignoranza
incredibile molti di voi probabilmente
non hanno ancora visto quindi nuova
partita io sono brent sono quei momenti
qui a che bella la mia infanzia non era
la mia facciamo 20 anni però erano ben
ricordi questo giocava una storia quindi
dobbiamo seguire la storia perché è
molto profondo queste mia moglie che mi
sta aspettando sull'altare un giorno
molto importante sono sempre in ritardo
console tesoro e che stavo mettendo a
posto il mio i miei capelli
eccovi non sono io quello fidatevi
ecco questo io sono questo non si è
stupito perché sono un polipo e si è
stupito perché non sono ancora vestito
capito io sono octo dead sono un po
perfetto sono un polipo che deve fare le
cose
voleva i cuscini va bene ma c'è una
chiave qua la chiave posso aprire il ok
ok per era difficile da giocare mi
ricordavo sta cosa bene io sono un
polipo e mi devo sposare e molti
presidenti
ok non sono stato io ragazzi versamente
la come può sembrare
esci dalla porta va bene primi la barra
spaziatrice per ok come come ha sempre
axept col mouse
va bene ma già sa già che si muoveva
così strano capisco
per me questa mia età tra cravatte devo
trovare in totale va bene lo sa aprire
la porta mi fai a prima non questo non
mi interessa la porta perfetto vero giro
ragazzi sembra una cagata è
difficilissimo da giocare sulla croce di
parte cav h questa era la mia torta per
dopo il matrimonio non prima posso
prendere questo il tasto qua strano
no forse dovevo aspettare di sposarmi
prima di prima porta dentro la torta era
mia però vabbè prendi la cosa che ci sta
sotto la cravatta perfetta siamo a due
bene non ho capito da star la nostra
latte ma vabbè dell'asl in parole povere
sto polipo a una famiglia una moglie
la gente non sa che un polipo c'è lui in
realtà sa di esserlo però non deve farlo
scoprire agli altri e tra l'altro lui
parla tutto borbottando come avete visto
prima e la gente lo capisce o come
pietro non fatemi domande grazie cerca
indossa lo smoking vai let's go bari c'è
un'altra chiave la prendo sono skillato
e cioè non penso di sì è così bravo mi
serve per la porta qua perfetto no cav h
c'è chi ha inventato sto gioco è un
genio non sono io non ho mai capito chi
è che ha inventato sta roba ma mi ha
fatto passare veramente dei pomeriggi
incredibili sono contentissimo di
rigiocarlo magari senza la seria senza
la sedia non serve ok al proprio nel
perfetto ho preso e indosso perché ne so
io come si indossa indossano mettitelo
l'evento e di qua perfetto perché mi si
attaccano le robe alle ventose ma è
difficilissimo cosa passa sotto bravo
zio
vai alla cappella d'accordo messo non
vedo niente ci siamo ragazzi che sei
gran momento potete piangere se volete
io devo indossare il mio consueto
cappello come sia qualche perfetto
prendi indossa indossando si indossa su
indossa già all right mendez è un
momento importante questo per me è la
mia vita
siete salve
no no non volevo fare tesoro
devo prendere l'anello da me va bene
l'anello è
speca arrivo l'anello l'anello e devo
prendo è intestato non lo so devo fare
meno rispetto che lo prendono solo c'è
un pesce e questo messaggio in modo non
ho idea di dove sia l'anello devo
aspetta un secondo
non devo fare troppo casino perché
faccio troppo casino si accorgono che
sono un polipo la barra viola indica il
casino che sto facendo a eco dentro
mettila ma quanto grosso sta nello eh no
non le devi allungare il braccio di più
però ti sta da dio secondo me non lo
perdi neanche sono marito fantastico che
bello scene che mi ero dimenticato wow
comunque una storia d'amore migliori di
twilight a pensa la questione in crediti
come ho fatto a non giocarlo più in
tutti questi anni
va bene ragazzi che se off preparatevi
all'ignoranza della bce proprio dovete
andare dal vostro migliore amico dire o
questo video di guardare voli parigi
apre testate per immergervi in un mondo
meraviglioso chi era sul mio canale
quattro anni fa occhio da eder gli
sketch e preparatevi al quoziente
intellettivo più elevato che voi abbiate
mai visto
questa è la dura vita di un uomo sposato
che si alza buongiorno io dormo in
smoking ovviamente tutto questo mia
moglie non si è mai accorta che sono un
polipo perché visto trascinando tempo
ero proprio io la mattina a sole due del
pomeriggio
come fai a dormire a quest'ora barca
vacca che sfaticato peggio di mese salve
papa si è alzata è vero che ero
dimenticato di spiegarvelo questi sono i
miei figli come fanno essere usciti
umani non fate domande gli arcobaleni da
dove vengono
lo so chiedilo alle persone omosessuali
da dove vengono i fiori qui devo
chiedere a pietro invece da dove vengono
i bambini basta fare queste domande sono
un polipo non sono anche parlare sono in
cucina giorno l'amore mi interessa
mangiare possibilmente colazione schifo
o mangia mangia mangia hanno preparato
il caffè non avevo letto scusa va bene e
non sono studiato scusami perfette
forte lattea stessi del latte spetta
tesoro e questo e del caffè che dove di
latte che ne so io il tesoro mi sono
incastra ok no vieni vieni amore noi
stessi e mia figlia non mia moglie porco
schifo devi essere guardato madre per
forza ma ora è papà ti ha portato del
buon latte vieni aspetta che devi un po
di caffè arrivo fate bella questa casa
se non fosse che e vabbè pago io latifah
che mette a posto
grazie tesoro aspetto che devo ok
vai nel cortile sul retro subito che
meraviglia di gioco ragazzi questo è
veramente non so come ho fatto a mano
giocando per tutti questi anni orca
vaccamorta dopo prendere un po di palle
in meno perché non riesco a prenderlo o
no che su taglia tra caffè con che
maestria sto facendo tutto questo
comunque ragazzi è più bravo di me a
gestire la casa su questo non ci piove
ciao bab come stai
e difficilissimo regalo lo giuro nel
prato logistico sta parlando quel gesù
che anzi a tagliare il prato cosa devo
fare gli altri taglia la legna strappa
l'erbacce prepara esservi in tavola la
carne va bene carne meno male che non
mangiano pesce sono poteva essere un
problema poi tesoro aspetta
mi spiace non volevo fare tesoro l'ho
visto fare in un programma di cucina si
sbatte così sul tavolo la carne viene
più saporita guarda ad emetterla proprio
su i pad i cosi sicuro prepara vuol dire
che la devo cuocere quelle carne cruda
ma è inizio neppure ma perché michele di
così capace come fuoco
beh questo è cotto top no non è da enna
a cosa serve sta roba
mi sto facendo malissimo alla mano ma
non fa niente amore cosa stai scrivendo
su quel foglio lì non puoi semplicemente
darmi una mano visto che io non ho mani
questo è hamburger salsa di polipo
praticamente c'è su quanto difficile
fare poi non avrò mai figli polipi tra
l'altro strappa le erbacce dal giardino
o finalmente un lavoro che mi si addice
sono queste delle erbacce cose qua ok
che bravo taglialegna come taglialegna
ci sembra un fusto con gli addominali
forzuto e le ascelle pelose da poter
tagliare legna
vabbè proviamo cioè cosa mi serve
tagliare della legna poi salì ceppo
rigau come vendite a casa per uccelli
tranquillo ci penso io tesoro
porca vacca ma chi è questo ferma lo
chef dita serventi servita è vero noi il
mio acerrimo nemico lo chef devo
buttarli qualcosa nel caso di prodotto
ayako moglie non mi dare una mano è per
l'amor di dio è riuscito a lanciarli
nomine tagliaerba lui è il mio
antagonista e lo chef che vuole
cucinarmi perché sai che sono un polipo
cioè il bottino di scuse comiche fammi
vedere
aspetta aspetta sono i miei compaesani
quelli dell'acquario va bene tesoro
certo il mio marco vario borbottio di
negazione qui biologica e bellissima
quindi ragazzi anche oggi concludo octo
red sempre più sensato ma non me lo
ricordavo così però è veramente figo ve
lo giuro che cosa ne sto facendo della
mia vita
solo che vide vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
cosa che se vi piace tanto mi piace
ancora i soci minuto per chi sia esso
consiste in seguito da ragazzi
[Musica]